gonna start rolling get it welcome to
the lapping bottles i'm trying to figure
out how to uh you know
get my hat set up like a mesh here
what's up what's up you know i put these
upside down
i have i do have more hat experience
right at this point but basically
hold on what do you do you see the
headphones upside down
upside down i put them backwards like
the other way like i
like this is the other side and this is
the other side bing bang
oh no okay no that's not i don't know
you have a
yours are just not tight enough if you
put them down i guess no they're not
tight enough dude got a large head
man you keep saying you got that big ass
head dude i don't know how you
should you know like your big your big
head should be holding those
you know no no because gravity if if
they're on top of my head they will but
gravity's weighing them down right now
right wow dude two silly ass hats
and mine has a print under it i'm such
an [ __ ] dude here's what i'm gonna do
dude
you're so happy about your hat and i
have to go get this hat i'm so happy
about this hat i know dude you got a
like sexy hat too dude i took my knee
so this one you know where i got this
baby boy
where husky gas station just down the
street 12 bucks
i took my niece for a gas station
milkshake and the lord said you know
what amish get a hat get yourself a hat
you did good today get yourself a hat
this hat is so silly dude
i love it man i'm telling you the hat
wardrobe is on point with you you
inspired me to get the set
i'm just having to do this just because
the the headphones are never gonna fit
me so
that's fine we're just gonna have to do
a top hat look here today yeah
dude one thing i want to get to i mean
i've been waiting since
for three weeks to get to this okay
the flying olympics
are you are you talking about uh
maharishi mahesh yogi
oh dude i've been waiting to talk about
this literally
for three weeks i have the clip
i've had do you have the official
like olympics or do you have the
announcement video what do you got
because i got
i got video dude i got good videos you
got the video you got the video because
the solid cut and everything
bro pull it up okay okay but first set
the stage because you told me about this
so this is sort of your segment i don't
want to take away your segment from you
this is like your snl
moment maharishi mahesh yogi
love him he is they called him they
called it mick meditation
he came out in the 80s classic story he
got a
he got just a million white people kind
of like the yoga guy
he just got like the right white people
right now seinfeld is doing speeches for
him
david lynch foundation oh david lynch
the filmmaker his entire foundation is
dedicated
to transcendental meditation which is
maharishi mahesh yogi's
system so this guy is the transcendental
meditation guy
yes dude and he had vp he's gigantic
he's huge man we're talking osho level
numbers
i'm surprised the documentary hasn't
come out because i don't think he
i don't know if he did anything like
that i think he had i think the issue
with him
is his teaching is this okay i'll give
you the whole thing he teaches this type
of meditation
that is a very it's a beautiful
meditation it's a very powerful
meditation like
it's like it's like he took loving
kindness he added a little bit to it
but a trick to his thing is that you
have to
there everyone has a special mantra see
in us
we are alive because of the most high
universal source
and that is available to all of us and
we are a children of that and we live it
and we invite we are gods on earth
living a video game of loving kindness
and we have an unlimited source of this
and there's a special mantra that if you
say the mantra you can go deep in
and to get that i can give you the
mantra but that's two thousand dollars
okay
see this is it this is this guy's pitch
no way it's 2 000 to find out your
mantra
how have i never i okay somehow i knew
that transcendental meditation wasn't
like
was about the mantra but i somehow
missed the fact that you have to pay
two thousand dollars to unlock the
secret to the universe
to your mantra like you have a special
one you're a child of the most high
universe oh
child of god why hasn't god has created
a mantra for you oh you don't know it
two thousand dollars
that's that's the sales pitch of the
original but they love it
they all love him the hollywood
christian bell like seinfeld
all of them love it well no the reason i
know about it is seinfeld i'm a huge fan
of seinfeld
and he's like a gigantic any chance
he'll get he gets he'll talked about the
transcendental meditation
seinfeld are you a fan of the beatles do
you like the beatles of course
the beatles wrote i think the white
album at his ashram
and they like they might have talked
about a minute
yeah the beatles wrote i think i'm
pretty sure their white album they wrote
it at
maharishi this guy's like a rock star he
teaches them the meditation and
because here's the thing and and this is
something that is taught in the buddhism
too
but sorry if you weren't saying
something go ahead no go ahead no i was
just
it it is taught that that that you see
when you when you are in this moment
you create a divide between the future
and the past and you create a portal
into the most high universal source
and that is an endless source of
creativity and energy that is accessible
to all of us now i do believe that on
some you know i know it sounds crazy
you know to just go up on educational
youtube or something like that but
i mean i think it's true you know what i
mean and a christ consciousness is very
similar
they talk about that now with when the
beatles were there they talked about him
like
and david lynch talks about him like
this too you go into that
you're in source brother and and it's a
beautiful teaching he's telling you that
you
it's everything you want to do is easy
he hits you with that 2k though
and you block it i know but maharishi is
in you with the 2k now he has the
beatles
but this is the thing about my boy
maharishi i love that like you
have like you like have the guy i got
the beatles who do you have
oh i got david lynch yeah i got
starkville like i bet this guy's like
talking to all his like
like that like the guys he he grew up
with in india he's like
hey man look you got them but hey i'm
over here in america i got the beatles
you ever heard of them
have you ever heard of them but here's
the best part dude the beatles wasn't
enough for maharishi
yogi maharishi yogi said he said he said
he said how can we take it to another
level okay
he said how can we take it to another
level i love this and he said
he said the people need a miracle the
people need magic and we're going to
take it to him
and he invented a new sport let's check
it out
oh hey pause it pause it real quick
pause it real quick pause yeah he
emitted a new sport what did he call
that new sport we got to set everything
up real quick
uh yogic flying this is a new practice
he has a tight meditation he's got the
beatles
he's got the beatles and he literally
can retire on that
yeah but he said you know what let's
take it to another level
that's not enough good you're gonna love
this yogic flying was unveiled to the
world in july
1986. dude he made an olympics did you
hear that
did you hear that this guy flying
was unveiled
yogic flying was unveiled to the world
in july 1986
look at the crowd but this was far from
the aeronautics display the world's
press had been promised
it was a characteristic exaggeration by
marshy
and one that detracted from the
credibility he'd worked so hard to
achieve
we hope to give you a glimpse today hold
on pause that pause that pause
yeah it's playing slow actually because
stop sharing real quick i gotta
i gotta share because i i found a high
quality found a high quality hold on you
found that
okay first of all first of all
not flying it's not flying not flying
not flying and these poor idiots like
they love him and they believe in him so
much that i get oh yeah this is
dude they were measuring on this video i
saw this video too this is great
they measure on this this is the flying
competition and here's the thing guys
last time we talked about levitation
this is flying
flying
[Laughter]
dude if you pause it you can catch them
flying look at this guy he's flying look
look at the pain models behind him
look at the technique i didn't even
notice the models behind him you think
they're really into the yogic flying
i mean they're into yoga [ __ ] like
they're into flaky [ __ ] too right like
they're into crystals they're into yoga
meditation i get it
and then i think he just shoved him into
a new direction and maybe he brainwashed
a bunch of them
optimizing brain functioning through the
transcendent meditation oh my gosh
come on look at the measurement system
that's a measurement those wait
stop stop
look at this guy look at this guy
look at this guy go okay look at this
guy look he's tracking him he's
real careful look at this guy right here
look they're wearing
suits man they have integrity they know
what they're doing get them up get that
mark it marker watch it marker why isn't
there a camera
oh how is nobody laughing oh my god this
guy over here
like with the beard the beard action's
got it going on
is he the rishi guy no he's not even i
think
no the rishi guy has passed away at this
point so these poor suckers
he told them like never ending fly i bet
he was on his deathbed
and he said every year you're like
please can we end the yoga flying
dude his ceo is like a [ __ ] lawyer in
holland this guy
he talks about it with so much pride
he's like uh yogi flying will continue
every year and
uh the maharishi said so we must
continue
people even just in their hotel room
quietly practicing together would be
enough to reduce
the level of violence the level of okay
i don't care about internet all i care
about is the flank
dude this is like the final boss this is
the final boss they have to stack
mattresses
yep bing bang oh my gosh
hey hey honestly honestly
we should try this this is fun eh this
is fun
this would be fun this would be fun
let's try it i want to see how high you
can jump
yogic fine i'm gonna try to yoga fly too
film
let's no no no seriously let's film our
efforts yogic fly and next time
we will show the crowds who is the true
yogic flying master i don't know i
everything i have springs are you using
springs
we need a certified oh we need springs
like we
really need to do this right i'm saying
i'm saying like i
i'm trying to think of like what i'm
trying to think of like look i got a
bunch of mattresses in the house
but if you if i but we also have a
sponge now i go to that sponge
and you come at me with spring mattress
we're gonna i don't know man
oh i might have to say something i can't
come come come at you with a
tempur-pedic
yeah you come yeah dude do you see those
tempur-pedic ads they're bouncing you up
they're cheating man we gotta get it
yeah okay all right we're gonna have to
behind the scenes get like some
regulation
but yeah i'm gonna try to do this hey
i'm not even sure i can get into the
lotus i mean respect to them for getting
in the lotus
yeah they have that permanent lock-in
lotus too
yeah you don't have to do that man i
mean good meditation
zen is the best teaching it's free you
don't pay a dollar
absolutely incorrect i have to do this i
have to you have to do this yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
other people can do it that thing the
training videos are there the training
videos are there you can you can train
and dude
they look like a video game or something
or like a cartoon oh my god
what are they doing this is so cute all
white too right
what is like what look at look at this
guy right here
in the front like front like like he's
really bopping up and down he's bopping
is he asian he looks maybe asian
oh i don't know i don't want to say but
like everyone's
everyone's white man and that's when you
know you made it man as a hindu cult
leader
okay you got 50 000 brown people fine
you need to go to sweden and get them
you need to go to the united states and
get them so epic what happens if like
the guy behind you starts hitting you
with his knees and it's like
i bet that's pretty annoying i mean they
probably talk about that like
listen when you're operating with the
most high most high you just it corrects
oh that guy's cheating did you see that
dude there are some cheaters in this
yogic flying look at this guy i think
when he's going
someone using hands yeah absolutely this
guy's look at this look look look look
catch him oh
oh oh oh oh oh hey watch it man
look we're watching he just push it look
he keeps doing it no no no no no no
are we is that allowed is that
regulation i don't think that's
regulation
we're gonna fight we're gonna find out
and we need the red marker on that
we're gonna get like he was touched we
gotta go we gotta go
man we gotta go to holland to dude it's
every year we can go to the
championships
what if you and i competed
yeah at the championships what if we did
kickstarter right now announcing
kickstarter right now coffeezilla
send us to sweden this is important work
yeah man i've been meaning to try it i'm
always just like what is
it is so silly though but dude they they
think they're doing moves one of them
he's doing like a kick flip
he bounces one and then he likes spin he
does a spin move
and i'm like this is a kick flip it's
like kick flip in
in skateboarding hold on let me i'm
trying to
oh this hurts that hurts ah
can you get in the lotus i can but why
do it you don't have to
like none of the teachings are like you
have to beat lotus zen doesn't do lotus
upload is i'm fully torqued load us up
if you're lotus down how are you why are
you why meditate like that
you're supposed to be comfortable i
can't jump
i have i have no idea how i'm going to
get from that
jump a little dude the jumping yeah
imagine all these guys came out with
like weird
like like like injuries amish i think
i'm going to take you to school
on lotus we should put a little bit of
money on it
okay that i care about oh i'm just
saying about it
i jumped you understand of course
we could do a long jump i mean we could
do a lot too yeah
long jump well one of us would win long
jump one of us when hydro and probably
yeah then it's a wash
the high jump is just like like you got
to get on top of like four mattresses
dude if i win i want your hat
okay fair okay i want to i want a
training montage more than i
you know what i mean like i just want a
training montage and like what song like
you know that like
like that like that there's that
there's one from karate kid oh yeah
what's that one it's like you are the
best
dance you go to the top
like we need a training montage like
that yeah we're training and then what
kind of exercises we got to do like some
yoga that'll like fix the knees after
massage therapy this is going to be
serious this is going to be serious
business in terms of uh
exercise i'm interested in how much it's
like is it going to make me sore like is
it
oh dude it looks like it's not going to
be exciting it looks like it's not good
for the
knees well they got some kind of special
padding and we do have to figure out
what that is
yeah um yeah regulation padding let's
look into you know we got to do
hey i think it's worth a kickstarter
maybe we could do a kickstarter
we'd be like hey let's go test it out
man what the heck is this
what yo i just found this guy literally
not playing at all
okay this is real levitation telekinesis
dude how can i get on whatever this
guy's okay okay
how's he doing this but why is there
abcd like why are these letters on the
screen
i think it's like yeah i don't know
okay oh man it's
okay well you know what now i'm gonna
have a hard time sleeping
thanks yeah you like this
you like this oh my god this is so
creepy oh god he's skipping now
what's the skipping for it's to show
that there's no
i guess no that's a dude overhead though
if he doesn't do it overhead then forget
it no it's probably
oh oh my god
okay now i'm not going to be able to
sleep at night great i'm scared
nightmares
no i'm fine i'm going to levitate you
know i'm excited he's got a crane right
above him just with a little cable
but then how's right out of shot rope
how does the rope go
there's always ways to do it like uh
like you probably
you know what it is okay so you know how
they do the levitating girl trick
on stage they have a crane behind her
and then the crane is like hiding
because she has a long dress and it
covers the crane so there's actually
like
so the girl is like being levitated on
stage and behind the curtain there's a
crane lifting them
so this guy i think they just cgi
because the camera is stationary
so you literally just cgi out the the
crane that's holding him up because if
the crane's holding him up and his hands
are by the crane then he can go over
can he no this one says unlike david
copperfield a master named alexander can
really fly
shots shots dude that's rude that they
just brought in another
magician yeah it is you do your magic he
does his guys
honestly though honestly though okay we
all know that that's there's some kind
of tom foolery going on there
uh but yeah where there is no
i mean where they're not messing around
is this i mean like there is no tricks
no like this guy is really doing that
this is straight up some just some
[ __ ] if you don't respect that i mean
oh no he got stuck did you see that that
was a hurdle that's going to be you dude
dude i'm going to be leaping over those
leaps
dude look man like that's that is
so low how could he not pass that hurdle
yeah it is so low i mean that's too low
he must have bounced wrong dude like
that referee do you see the referee with
the with the stripes
can you imagine how sad it would be to
hear about the yogic flying
competition if you didn't know what it
was going all excited and finding this
look the seats are empty towards the
this side but the other side is pretty
busy
look at this guy's shirt which guys try
piece
yeah like he has a referee like he's
taking this seriously man
and like look i know there's a lot of
empty seats back there but this is too
many people for a yogi flying
competition
it's straight up popping it's not bad
i mean they built it up they hyped it
and they got a turnout wow
see but you know what the real magic of
this is the magic is
is the maharishi got these people man he
got seinfeld yeah
yeah look this guy's not using his hands
though so definitely not
like hands must not be regulation hands
can't be regulation
there's no way yeah yeah and we'll be
watching that coffeezilla
we're watching your hands just keep
those hands off the bed
and we'll we're like freezing
honey i gotta get a new mattress why uh
yogurt's flying i got
it's training training mattresses we
need a line
the basement is now a yoga flight you
imagine
that's a divorce that's a divorce now
that's why you guys gotta leave your
wife you wanna get into yoga flying
that's it but those models do you think
they're into it dude anything for the uh
the uh oh show and
well he's not osho osho's uh i know the
gita just kidding the bog no no and now
now we will be the bog ones we are the
babas i mean ah so much to talk about
dude you're gone on vacation the biggest
sociopath i've ever seen in my goddamn
life
the biggest sociopath youtube put me
back on the install list i haven't been
getting pickup artist ads
for like two years i got rid of when i
was doing the packaging
yeah i'm gonna have some [ __ ] intel
list dude i start the ad
you're on vacation i'm like man we got
we need a coffee zilla right now i gotta
call this guy
it's such a i was offended this guy
basically i've never seen someone do
this no curtis connor shout out to
curtis connor he's a canadian youtuber
i did a couple of shows with him before
kobit i don't know if you know him but
uh
he did a video about this guy scott jack
and scott jack has a pickup artist ad
he's laying in bed with the girl and he
just does the ad like she's not even
there
okay rude weird whatever this new guy
he just points he's like see how hot she
is she see her i brainwashed her
i brought out your dumb little girl
brain i went in there bing bang bang she
wants to [ __ ] me
and i'll teach you how to do that too
join the webinar though join the [ __ ]
website
who is this i want to join this webinar
what is his name dude
i've gotta i gotta see this laughing
babas is subscribed to him
look let's look at his last dude his
email [ __ ]
oh we're going to talk about a little
bit of the emails that came through too
right
but um okay so we will we want one guy
at a time amish that's your brain
bouncing i'm so psycho um okay this guy
i i'm
actually offended though i i was in the
middle of his thing i sent you a
screenshot of it
i think his name is okay wait let me
look in the email
is it casey xander it might be casey
xander
and if you look at the top the the the
the um subject line is
baba sri baba which is what i said our
name was in our new email
that we made this is heartbreaking plus
masculinity group
blueprint 4k off ending soon
so we're getting the ads you know
laughingbaba's gmail.com oh my gosh
we gotta go here's the video i gotta
find this i gotta find this video right
here okay so dude
this is this is where i did some
coffeezilla work i learned how to
download a [ __ ] webinar
so i have a full webinar it's an hour
and a half and that's so offensive dude
it's so rude man this guy he okay so
first he does the [ __ ] ad with the
girl
then he the girl's in it with him in the
webinar set the stage can we can we play
the ad i want to play the ad
where's the um okay where is this ad the
thing is lately dude is people
do the ads and then they don't like let
me keep the video
that's why curtis connor when he did the
scott jack one i was like how'd you get
the video
because they will play these scam videos
then you go to their youtube not there
right it's a hidden ad
yeah it's a hidden ad yeah so i had to
figure so i don't have the ad but i do
have the webinar i can play you a bit of
if you want
because there's some choice pieces in
there and i think i sent you the sales
card hold on let me just pull
i just want everyone to see who this guy
is real quick
this is the first thing that i see semen
retention and why
men struggle with women yeah that's the
guy that's the guy oh of course
hey you know i don't have any problem
with monetization
until we do this show every show we've
done so far oh no all demonetized
because these psychos are calling us out
yeah and because we're probably talking
about semen retention
right but that's like the video that's
like what he's talking about dude that's
that's what this guy's talking about
that was the girl by the way if you
scroll up this girl was in the video so
this girl right here
this girl oh yeah that's the girl um
she's in the video and he's just
pointing at her like she's like look at
her look at this dum-dum i brainwashed
her brain i've erased her dumb brain and
i put in whatever the [ __ ] i want
and now she loves to [ __ ] me all the
time and then he looks at her she goes
it's true i love him
look how hot this guy is uncle c
back in the office today what i wanted
to do was
i wanted to answer the question from her
subscriber
subscriber messages me they say what's
your thoughts on seeing women while on
retention he goes i see it maybe kind of
counterproductive what he's teaching
like how to be like some kind of
spiritual
like this is guru advice because they
have to do these like celibacy things
so he's like basically teaching like how
to be a celibate wait
what how did that happen he like how
many videos does he have on semen
retention is that what this guy's all
about
he's so deep on how to keep your
i don't know he's like he's so into
pickup that he's like
anti figure he's like no no sex he's
like i'm the first oh
no that's interest that's interesting
he's like he's like i'm changing the
game dude
i'm changing the game i'm gonna pick up
girls but not actually pick them up
yeah like not actually have sex with
them i don't know it's a weird thing
like i mean it is a weird a bit of a
psych like a weird community where
i think they are crazy and like his his
webinar dude
it's so delusional but in the webinar
there is a lot of stuff like that where
his webinar a lot of it is him saying
you're going to get so much [ __ ] that
your dick's going to hurt
wait but i thought he's about like not
retaining your semen i mean what's going
on here like this guy's selling himself
is like i'm so i'm
like people want to [ __ ] me so much that
i'm on this next [ __ ] of like
the next level of just like not doing
anything no
i don't now i have to say no to them
i pick up so good and that's his sales
video okay so this is
this this sales webinar that he sends
okay he doesn't even
pretend like you know some people
they'll do like uh
all right guys uh put in a put in the
number one if you guys are uh if you
guys are glad to be here and excited
it's like
and there'll be like a bunch of fake
number ones and then they'll be like
yeah thank you
thank you like steven from mumbasa
thanks bro hey karen
yeah this guy doesn't even pretend he's
just his counter doesn't have the
numbers
but he's just saying like all right guys
the first five minutes of the video is
him saying
get a pencil get a paper you're taking
notes i don't waste my time if you're
not taking notes i'm not starting
i'm not starting get the pen get the pen
get the paper hit the number two i'll
say
then we'll start and he's just waiting
for the number two there's like
like two of them but he's saying there's
like okay we got all the
a couple more twos coming in but it
wasn't consistent
i don't like it i don't like this man
what is he doing this is it
how men are using mbt therapy patterns
to create create instant attraction and
hook
any girl they want without feeling
awkward or making
any moves oh my gosh
how to create attraction with your dream
woman regardless of income or height
dude
he should have said he just said even if
you're brown like dude i'm telling you
they do like you know at the seminars i
feel like they're talking we talked
about this last time
i like how they just throw in height
though they're looking for your
insecurities
oh yeah race height pain
raises dude i mean i think at the sales
seminars they're like hey get the sanjay
watch the sanjay
because they got like five sales guys
regardless yeah on a five thousand
dollar three thousand dollars
i love that these pickup artists are
like they don't ever consider
the whether the girl wants to be a part
of this to like create instant
attraction and hook
any girl you want like it's like the
desired thing is like just like be able
to magneto women into your life like
oh and they're like that's what she is i
mean she's playing that part i mean i i
maybe she's an actor maybe she's making
him do it dude for sure they hire her
fake a little like yeah they do hire
them maybe but but maybe she's
i don't know i don't know the guy's
webinar
is two hours um like five
this is how he stretches it up five ten
minutes he's doing
like just get your pencils get your
papers i'm not [ __ ] teaching this
[ __ ]
don't you know the value of writing down
the notes the things i'm gonna teach you
are so important
you need to get the [ __ ] pen get the
paper don't be a [ __ ] idiot this is
why you're not getting any [ __ ]
get in the pan get the paper like he's
just telling you for 10 minutes right
but then dude
like look some people like you okay
there's some pickup like dating coaches
there's things to teach
okay like even at a real social dynamics
thing they'll bring up the sun jay but
they'll be like hey bro stand tall
give you give a couple inches you know
girls like that you know go
do it this guy is like 35 minutes
is just you're going to get laid so much
you're going to get laid he doesn't
teach anything he just types
nothing he hyped you up he it's all hype
and 45 minutes of it is pro is like
price
because you know the price card comes in
on these scam people yeah once the price
card comes in
it's like okay this is closing time it's
all handling objections
yeah 30 minutes of price
that's i think that's the image i sent
you i sent you i texted you a thing
and it's basically dude his price card
is like we're talking about
oh my god wait where did i put it hold
up hold up hold up i got it i got it
does it look good is it on there we go
now all right guys welcome to the live
stream so this is going to be a
broadcast presentation where i'm going
to
okay so this is like we don't need to go
through so much of it but this is like
hours of like this is all like the
you're going to get delayed
so much you're going to get laid so much
section right
then he has this this like 50 year old
with i think he just found a picture
does he have in here he's like
see this sex slave i have five what's up
with that girl just like
first of all things i like demonetized
again
[Laughter]
this guy is a psycho he's hot though too
like he's pretty
so well and that's the whole irony too
it's like first of all
probably paid a lot of these women but
secondly secondly
yeah uh let's not pretend that if you're
just some random guy who look like does
not look like this
you're gonna get you know any woman you
want this is really
time wise it doesn't make sense you
don't want this much
one a year two a year it's fine
how many are you running through i was
talking to some guys telling me like
he's telling me like he sleeps with 22
girls a month i'm like okay you're not
doing any work
right take us off stop share i need to
react to this the people need my
reaction here oh yes yes yes
okay stop sharing stop sure go rip it
say it again you won't believe this
such a psycho dude no that that's ex
that's extreme dude i i
want no one man should have all that
power that's all i gotta say yeah and
i'm not knocking it like do it but are
you getting any work done
right come on how do you have time to
to woo all these women where's time like
hey get hey
we don't have time for this getting
better
that's right part of the program is you
brainwash them so good but no tips
no tests 45 minutes of that and then it
is like a
full half hour okay let me show you the
price screen real quick is that cool
yeah dude oh yeah sure i'm gonna show
you the fry ice
computer okay girl check this out this
just keeps going oh god it's a whole
oh he's such a i could not i did not
so want to check if these i bet a bunch
of these photos are stock photos i don't
know
but what if they're just all stock
photos no guaranteed okay there's a
picture of a 55 year old man
with it like for sure stock photos with
the girls but there's a picture of a 55
year old man
with his 22 year old daughter and he
puts that picture up and he's like
man chad is getting laid so much he's
banging everyone and i'm like dude
is that did you just find a guy in his
daughter
and said that he's like this guy's like
90 and he's just banging all the time
like that was one of these examples
i think it was at 16 minutes it was like
somewhere
ah
this is ridiculous dude look at all this
this is ridiculous dude
somewhere i can only imagine just being
like some like
acne ridden kid who's insecure and
seeing this guy and thinking
oh my gosh this is the secret that
everyone's using but
okay okay she doesn't look 20 actually
so but this is the guy
this is the guy oh my gosh money will
never matter stupid dude
stupid what a stupid statement
money is the last thing that negotiates
attraction i mean he's basically saying
like
mike is an anesthesiologist making one
meal a year and was still getting dumped
left and right
okay um wow money will never
i mean it's a good sales trick because
it's like just give me five thousand
dollars now because
okay this this is what's [ __ ] up too
where i think i send this
text from an anesthesiologist had to
have the word melons in it
oh yeah it's basically like he has like
a sample sample sample
but this is what i mean by like no no
tit no
like tamp i feel like what are we
looking at oh bing bang price on this
call
yeah hey but you can launch today at
7.97
wow wow that cheap price dude i love
that these guys pretend like they ne
have actual scarcity it's such a great
like
oh this yeah it's so stupid
that's what the money time is right i'm
gonna hit stop show on this
oh yeah the money time i find when the
money time hits
that's when you really got to twist the
knife and be like oh and they and it's a
lot of objection handling they call it
yeah well the the big objection is why
buy today
why should i buy tomorrow and they go no
don't buy them
tomorrow it'll be four times as
expensive you don't have a choice
this is the only call you can get it on
it'll never be anywhere else dude
that's literally what they say like like
you can't re-enroll with like another
email
like like exactly just email you get the
exact same deal
this is the only deal you're ever gonna
get look i've given five thousand
dollars
today only tomorrow you come with five
thousand cash i'll say sorry
dude who was who are you talking to that
was saying that they were so obsessed
i was watching one of your podcasts the
guys it was like it was like um
a guy he was saying that a guy flew in
to give a deposit
so some guy remember what you're talking
about dude this is on your podcast i
know you were telling me you were
talking to this guy
he was he got scammed by a guy it's one
of your episodes man dude you're doing
so much work eh
you're creating so much content
he was saying that some guy flew in jets
that fly no no
okay it wasn't that he just flew in
there was a convict that
broke probation to go out of like like
he was supposed to stay in like a little
like area
and he wanted to be in the deal so bad
and it had to be like cash or whatever
and so he i if i'm remembering right he
drove and broke his own like probation
parole
to try to get yeah to try to get the
course wow
that's how this affects people well
because look
here's the thing this is not uh
it's not typical like it's not typical
scarcity
most salesmen don't do this level of
scarcity this is like ratcheted up
ratchet up dude you gotta like you gotta
hit him where it hurts man and he does
it a lot man he's very bullying this guy
he's so mean man he's like casey
alexander dude i mean what are you gonna
do when you're
retaining something he's full of that
you know he's got the city
in him so he's aggressive as [ __ ] he's
so mean to the girl too like he's just
like
like bossing her around and stuff i mean
you know what i bet he's
whipped behind the scenes dude i bet
he's whipped like maybe she's just a
really smart writer
and she's because he does sound like
such a dumb hick right
really he sounds silly like in the thing
he talks slow and he's very
he's got a good voice he talks very slow
and he's and i find it's a lot of like
like maybe i'm just obsessed with fargo
but i feel like they're going for that
like people will put on and politicians
do it too you put on a southern you put
on a nice country like
hey man i'm just one y'all damn hey hey
man
that's one of you guys i just wanted
just like you man
you know like they do that it's it's an
endearing tactic it is
um it it's just such a smart sales
technique even politicians like
we had this thing amish tell me this
if you weren't a laughing baba how close
were you to buying the course
no come on this is
this i was this is too much day one
offense minute one
i'm like come on man you can't put the
girl in it like that and just she's like
yeah yeah yeah this is a lot
you can't do this it's a lot to handle
and i was very offended by the
lack of information man well it's just
who do you think their target
demographic is
it's like kids who think that that's
like real life yeah
someone who needs just learned the mind
control tactic
it's a mind control tactic yeah do you
have you ever heard of wesley billion
dollar virgin
uh i'm still getting into it but he has
been advertising to me so okay
he's in our list actually he's one of
the mind control hacks guys
and the start of his webinar he goes hey
i was in the army and i got like
basically booted out but not before i
saw like
the mind control tactics of the like of
the army basically of the military
wow and i'm going to share it with you
and and his first screen is like
a cia warning screen it's like photoshop
it's like warning warning cia
yeah yeah yeah yeah wow dude you know we
got an email from someone
um at mindcontrol101.com you know that
what's minecraft101.com we got an email
dude this mind control business
the cia mind control people going on
this is a big subculture that we have
somehow tapped into brother
because we got an email from mr barron
aka dantalian jones
and um he he somehow like shout out to
him for getting this email
he basically has the equivalent of like
mind control is my business at gmail.com
and then when i reply i was gonna reply
to him and be like hey man thanks for
the email like his email was hilarious
but i was gonna reply and it replied
auto back to support
mind control 101.com oh she doesn't even
have any
so he got mind control is my business at
gmail.com
but then he also when i replied he also
does have a supporter
support at mindcontrol101.com
you said like hey can you control my
mind a little more like yes
yep you're starting that down your mind
control's not working at the support
we'll be right with you sir support mind
control
the support is like here just watch this
guy's seminar you know like you're just
watching a woman oh my gosh they're
looking for leadership you know
mind control publishing it looks like
alex jones website and his graphics oh
it does dude
hey what do you think of alex jones
i mean i think okay i'm wondering now
obviously he's a psycho like he's got
mental health issues he's from texas
right
dude hey and we claim him
yeah dude okay listen here's the thing
he says some crazy stuff yeah
and basically everything he says is
crazy but dude the guy is entertaining
he's living proof that if you're
entertaining enough
you're almost uncancelable because he
still is like running his show and doing
pretty well
even though he's banned off every
platform i think he's the only human
that is banned off of every platform the
cancel [ __ ] needs to stop
man even when they get the right person
it's dumb
people don't get it man you can't go
murder him then you can't do that you
can't cancel the person because
here's the thing his credibility comes
from you canceling him
yeah did you get it idiots his he builds
his audience
saying look the liberals are after me
again that's how they build their
[ __ ] audience
like fox news war it's a war
it's it's proof of the war that he's
being cancelled
yeah you proved it dude these liberals
are so
they're so easy to trick like i mean and
and the thing is you watch all these
roger dale's documentaries and how he
built fox news
and he's they're laughing man they're in
the back room they're doing that like
um obama is that he does a fist bump
with his wife obama
in the documentary but it's in the book
too the guy talks about this he does a
fist bump
and on the fox news they're like is it a
terrorist fist
jab what are they doing why is the
president some kind of a muslim
and in fox news like all these liberals
are freaking out fox news they're
laughing
they're like can you believe that [ __ ]
yeah no we got it on buzzfeed like
they're joking they don't give a [ __ ]
they're laughing about it don't you get
it like this is how they trick you know
what i mean
they keep falling for it it's so sad
yeah
and i've been watching a lot of people
so it's interesting a lot of people have
been getting canceled this week amish i
don't know if you've been noticing
uh yeah yes
hey um you talk about comedians because
we have a comedian oh yes dude hey
hey i've been dying to talk about this
okay uh that's an interesting case
because um he gets like called out right
all these women come out and i'm like
all supportive and like i love
i love that i want all those stories to
come out but then like
he releases a bunch of emails that show
that he the girls weren't actually
underage yeah like and then it's like
wait he's already done though he's
already like he's lost everything
oh no has he oh yeah mainstream tv yeah
it's all out yeah
[ __ ] that that's all done fair enough
caa dropped him
like just in the eyes of the public
he's like a monster but he did wait
technically on but here's the thing in
the eyes of the public he's getting the
judgment of a guy
who will text a 17 year old and be like
hey i'll text you back in here when
you're 18.
18's a lot and this is so i don't know
in america they're going
seinfeld james franco they're [ __ ] 17
year olds hey
isn't 20 enough can we just wait till
20. like it's just rude right like it's
rude
in the culture in a weird way and it's
almost like a personal cancel
it's a bunch of people being like you're
gross and we don't like you yeah yeah
yeah
well is it is super creepy though like
if you're like
40 years old and you're like texting
like an 18 you're like hey what's up
it's like i mean for a guy that based so
much of his personal brand on being like
cool
yeah there's not that much that's cool
about like dating someone
who's just got out of high school yeah
it is weird man
it's unless you're chase xander or
whatever his name is
like yeah yes hey actually that
he might have been a course taker yeah
he might have taken the course
delia might have uh get these yeah
get him i mean he like you got to learn
to be a sociopath i guess right like it
is is it this generational thing of like
sociopaths teaching younger people i'm
not talking about crystallia
talking about this guy like you want to
be careful dude what if crystallia comes
back and then you've said a bunch of bad
stuff about them
i don't care i mean look crystallia like
it's fine i was i wasn't
like the other issue with him is that
that's his fan base a little bit too
it's all girls like but it's all those
party girls
and it's all club it's like club younger
club people it's like he took the dane
cook crowd right
so this just keeps happening to them man
they do
like it's almost like that comic does
comedy for
these people that they all kind of want
and ask for
and then after the end of it it's like
we've all decided you're sexist now i
mean
it is a culture correction i guess they
did it with dane cook too was like
he was just with a 19 year old and
everyone's mad at him about that the guy
who plays superman's banging a 19 year
old
and they people are like you know we
don't like it
it's i don't know you got to just pick
your battles i guess too with chris it
is weird to just cancel him over that i
don't know
it's like well his problem was he didn't
release the stuff forever
he like waited like 10 days but that's
why i think that he probably just had
sex with a bunch of 17 year olds like
that's the text message that came out
behind the scenes that's my
conspiracy-ish theory he probably just
is that he was afraid of stuff coming
out and like he's like let me wait to
see if it like the real evidence comes
out
and then i'm gonna say behind the scenes
just
a bunch of girls got paid like a hundred
thousand dollars
that's very pop it's very possible don't
because
that's too much and i'm i have to spend
two years digging myself out of this
he'll spend two years digging himself
out he'll maybe never work on tv and
stuff again but he'll definitely just
have his podcast back
yeah but he probably will work in tv
again like the funny thing about cancel
culture is it's extreme
at the time but then also maybe it
doesn't really last like people don't
stay mad
and then the fans who were fans they
like go back they kind of silently start
trickling back in
the you know the rafters and then
eventually they're packing out the house
again
that's what it looks like it's gonna
happen with him louis ck like look man i
know they did bad stuff and you want to
you want to give them a spanking and i
guess that's all it is like you can't ca
we maybe need to stop calling cancel
just give them a break
pause timeouts
and basically work your way back in
johnny depp's doing it johnny depp
is like she was beating the [ __ ] out of
him from what i can tell
right like what was happening on that
one man and then one time and then i saw
a thing where she was dating elon musk
for a minute and he's out with a black
eye dude this girl hates him
and he has video johnny depp has an
audio of
her being like so what if i punched you
will you stop being a little [ __ ] like
she's yelling at him
he's not waiting like two months ago
it's like everyone canceled him
and everyone look everyone did all the
main networks
they did put out official like hey we we
can't see johnny
yeah no no i'm talking about like they
did that cancel him because he was
abusive to his like his wife
called him out at the time right right
but then a year or two later like he
just maybe like four months ago he
released these tapes
of her clearly
being you know maybe having mental
health issues i don't want to like blame
her or anything like that
maybe he's have some mentality maybe
anger management and saying hey
if i punch you in the face stop being a
little [ __ ] about it piece of [ __ ]
like yelling at him okay and he puts the
tapes on every network
has officially said like hey we were
wrong to cancel johnny depp
but who gives a [ __ ] the cancel is
salacious
it's a sexy story yeah we talk about
that all day it is but
oh it turns out that he's not i don't
care
the same people that canceled it like we
got to do they're not even going to come
back and be like
none of them have said sorry like
whatever i don't know it is a time where
you just kind of go
whatever we're not allowed to go and
fight for these people like you know
what i mean it's just a weird spot where
it's like
i guess men have been so shitty for so
long
that we're gonna do a wave of like
cancelling people i mean this happened
al franken too man
it was like a right-wing hit job they
were just [ __ ] with him even the girl
came out who called al franken out she's
even come out saying like
i didn't think he had to quit you know
what i mean
did she said it she's at the time being
like oh he's a creepy
yeah our culture just doesn't know how
to deal with anything except for like
you're cancelled
like you can't work anymore for a time
and then you can come back
and that's like yeah i don't know
it's been so damaging for the left that
i think they're starting to learn we're
seeing it with biden
where it's like okay that's all you got
now and ignore his cancel
he [ __ ] just oh well that's that's
just like yeah that's a thing of
convenience i mean i'm interested in
these new politicians who are running
have speaking of politicians let me play
you a quick song here
let's hit it oh hold on i gotta share my
screen you sure
yeah the audio doesn't come through
unless you share this happen to me too
[Applause]
21st century baby better than anybody
you ever seen do it's crazy
[Music]
that's right dude okay so uh we got to
talk about kanye speaking of politicians
dude hey
if kanye runs
trump's done as much as biden i don't
know i don't think it's a big name
we gonna vote yeah i would vote for you
goddammit i
love kanye island are so awful right now
put a kanye in yeah yeah dude honestly
like they're so dumb like honestly
they're so
[ __ ] these are your two options kanye is
a genius of course
i have uh well it's good
yeah you're just at a level where you're
like okay we've tried the politicians
we've tried the
the billionaire let's try throwing kanji
weston
and yeah i mean they suck that bad
that i'm like yeah okay
dude what i've realized is people are
looking at the presidency going
[Laughter]
it's uh yeah it is becoming that but a
level like it's it's just
it's been disrespected so much like
people just don't have
any respect for the presidency as far as
people just feel like anybody can run
for president now
yeah yeah i mean trump really lowered
that bar like the rest of them were at
least professional sounding
this guy was on tv three weeks ago
saying yeah we got the cure
quit alienating our trump voters dude
[Laughter]
we have trump trump voters in here and i
love you guys
i love you guys but you know your boy
said that he had a vaccine three weeks
ago come on man
he just says [ __ ] you know like bro he's
getting the best ratings though he's
getting the best ratings
yeah look he just he is he a doctor
maybe is he the greatest doctor possibly
you know um oh you mean like your boy uh
luther
you're talking about dude he's like he's
like yeah dude he's like a he's a he's a
doctor like luther dude
he is a doctor like he's a doctor of
like [ __ ] he conned everyone
he became the president that's the
ultimate doctor that's the ultimate
doctor move it's not even a fake it's
like i got in
but he is part of that lutheran
community that podcast was great by the
way man what great work you're doing
just calling him out how exhausting i
can't believe he went on there
oh my god what a psycho he does have a
young trump in him he's like a young
bullshitter like he's a young trumper
and like
you know what i'll say about him behind
the scenes
gentlemen i mean like after the thing i
it was rough i mean let's just be real
it was rough for him
yeah and after the thing he's like hey
man great to talk to you man if i can
ever do
anything for you let me know and i'm
like
yeah it's like it's a good move
it's sociopathy in the sense that like
he's only looking for
pluses i'm only looking for the wins
yeah
only wins and that's a great strength
that he has
you know i know i know it's terrible i
know it's like too bad that he's using
it for that
but like i i kind of like that about
that's the one thing that i liked where
he never
felt like he had to be rude he never
felt like he had to be like there were
moments where he got at you though there
were moments where he's like
i'm doing two million dollars of
business a month how much millions are
you doing like he was saying [ __ ] like
that to you i'm like hey hey
it got like a little ugly there i know
he was still soft-spoken
and just you know like he he kind of but
he did do these roasts of like
you're at you're catching him on [ __ ]
he's like no my assistant does that you
know how many assistants i have you
don't even have one assistant
like i'm like hey stick to the argument
baby like what is this kids going all
over you know caleb maddox did that too
because i was like i was like oh he's
like you think you're so old and wise or
whatever and he's like do you think
you've had more life experience than me
i was like
well by definition yes and he's like
he's like
oh you want to go down the list you want
to go down the list what have you done
how many companies have you started
how many planes have you been on
so caleb maddox though he's got hits on
his youtube he's like making big hits on
his youtube and [ __ ] right
now so like no he's not right it's like
no he just has a bunch of he just got a
bunch of ads running
yeah okay well if you're paying for the
hits it's [ __ ] like that community
to get hits up right now
it's like a skill and there are like
they're they're really flooding the
market with each other
there's so many i can't oh the gurus
yeah
they're flooding it well everyone just
realized what a profitable market was
marketed was and now it's all saturated
because everyone's promising the exact
same thing
and it's a ratchet upgrade like i'm
saying ratchet a lot today
it's you just uh go higher higher so i
saw like
i used to see copy and paste ads to make
like a hundred dollars a day
now it's all about copy paste ads to
make five hundred dollars
a day a day all you have to do is copy
paste
to make five hundred dollars a day no
the number upping
i love there's a guy [ __ ] chidester
tanner tanner chitest or something like
that
tanner he's his no no no it's chidester
i'm pretty sure it's chad scheidster so
crazy like that this he used to be a
personal trainer now he sells like these
quote these uh get rich quick
but dude his ad was like okay if you're
truly if you're looking to go
seven figure eight figure this is for
you seven figure eight figure people all
need
oh my god the athletes this isn't
hey if you're serious about business and
you're looking for a seven figure eight
figure
low input business then only do you
click this
seven figure eight figure people only if
you're thinking less than that i don't
really i can't really help you
like who's talking about it
if you want hey if you want a six figure
don't even bother
don't even bother with hey we can't help
you i've never gotten someone to
i've only i skipped six figures and go
to seven figures
it's a psycho i mean they're talking to
20 year olds
they're so lonely these young people
like guys are having a hard time with
masculinity we're hearing it a lot in
may and like
they're having trouble retaining their
uh semen
they're having attention coaches are
banging right now dude
no actually they're not i'm nine days
safe
spill free you see that you got a no fap
coach brother you got no fat
are you are you in the no fat oh you're
married you have to worry about all that
yeah i'm married baby
you you're actually doing it dude you
have to or i won't
do the work to have sex or have like a
relationship with a human being
you can't this you can't like one thing
i'll say i support is the no fat
movement
like don't be hard on yourself but porn
is an addiction man
it is its own scam and it's not worth
your time
i'm not to shame anyone no i get it i
agree with you getting addicted to it
completely agree yeah yeah so no i'm in
that nofap fam
i think it's starting to become a harder
camp to defend like the non-addiction
part like like i think it's
but yeah not i mean not to shame anybody
or anything i mean that's surprising
guys not hating man i mean no no i i
have a degree in buddhism as you know
and the highest teaching is loving
kindness i'm
not it's against my religion to judge
you you can only treat that with loving
kindness
and that's the most efficient way to fix
it you're a child of the most high
universal source okay
yeah and just you let it through and you
can't i mean it's not i don't think it's
good to berate someone about it
you know you're doing it because you're
ashamed of yourself already so you
didn't talk to any girls because you're
a shame shame
you know what i mean it's a bit it's a
circle man they're going to jerk off and
you're like i'm such an idiot and you're
going to trick off again
stop it and then these pickup bars
that's where they get you dude they get
you [ __ ] this guy jerked off nine
times
get him can i tell you something can i
say something
youtube they sent me like a bad letter
like a shame on you letter
the other day no because of me because
of you
well because okay every time so they've
started to do this thing where you can
like pre-rate
your videos right and i always say
totally no i always say it's totally for
everyone like anyone
like it's totally like safe for work in
other words there's nothing mature about
this right and that normally that's true
but uh i guess i didn't think about our
videos too much and so i
i was just always marking them and the
other day they came back to me they go
steven
anytime you're demonetized you have a
zero percent chance of no
like rating your video correctly and i
was like i was like zero percent chance
and then they're like yeah and not only
do you have a zero percent chance but
you're wasting our time because you keep
appealing videos that are like
demonetized
and then you're getting re-demonetized
because they're still they're like
you're not
judging it correctly they're basically
saying i don't know my own content and
i'm going why do they think that why
don't they trust me and i click on my
videos like what videos
did i not rate correctly me
oh my god dude you're gonna start
releasing these on this
laughing baba's gmail we're gonna have
to have like a an x-rated channel
i guess oh my god offensive oh my god
sorry dude
just say not safe for kids because on
mine it says when i'm trying to upload
oh yeah well no no that's a different
that's a different thing okay
yeah yeah mine's not for it's not made
for kids right
you're in that 100 000 sub club yeah
yeah sub club maybe yeah they're like
did you get a plaque no dude no no
hey i haven't gotten a plaque for my
other channel yet
oh your other channel is way past way
past where the [ __ ] are they they should
be coming over here too goddammit hey
i know i'd have my plaque right back
there no plaque dude
no luck that would look like on this one
youtube
oh don't even get me started dude god's
work over here you have a lot of beefs
with youtube
you know what it is because this [ __ ]
con artist they're they're [ __ ] with
you with youtube
that's what i think okay listen all
right
i've been meaning to talk about this for
some time because
a good buddy of mine named will scott
he's a youtuber okay
oh yeah shout out to wilson you're gonna
like i love this stuff
you're gonna love this yeah i saw your
mug i liked your mug on instagram
oh guys get that get the wheel scooter
mug great guy get that get the bell
squadron
but dude okay i've got to tell you he's
been working on a show
oh dear for two years
one no two youtube videos he's been
working on two youtube videos for two
years
and they're all about happiness
which is right up your alley right up
your alley right he's so good
he's so good right he starts so tight
like that's such an amazing shows his
grandparents
right like is he that's what's going
right he has he has a letter from his
grandfather to his grandmother saying
like
oh you you you do know him yeah yeah
[ __ ] with him he's
but okay he just released the first
episode
and you are going to you're going to
lose your mind so
i want to just uh you know
tip my hand a little bit and i want to
just show you
like this this honestly is too good for
youtube
he is so good man it's too good for
youtube such a great writer
will's too good for youtube he's so good
but like
i just want to encourage everyone to go
watch it because this
video he basically sacrificed the
youtube algorithm which wants you to
upload constantly
for actual quality and i just want to
see him
rewarded to the extent that he deserves
to be he deserves it man he does
incredible work
look at this animation dude this
animation's
tight dude it's so tight he's tight all
the way through man always
this guy's so good and he's like taking
on super meaningful topics he refuses to
be like
sell out to like uh you know the
interests
like i don't know if you know
educational youtube but it's basically a
cesspool of like
half-baked research i mean let's just be
i'm from that world okay so i of all
people know that
um the science has to be correct
no there are let me let me see this let
me say this there are a lot of really
good people
in educational youtube i don't want to
throw shade but they will resonate with
this the incentives incentivize you to
just half-bake content and just like
pump it up oh yeah that's just how
that's how
all of youtube works and so i want to
see no it's
dude it's true i just thought of a
psycho that i want to tell you about in
a second but go on i wanted to encourage
you
and everyone from this channel to please
go spend an hour of your time watching
that show
it's going to be way better than
laughing baba's i hate to change one
hour it's one hour
it's one oh it's 46 minutes but yeah oh
my god
no honestly youtube is as a culture the
cream is rising man
he's tight dude this guy's incredible
check it out i'm with it man i'm with
you on that he's so good
and he took a year to make it so it has
to be better than laughing about hey
we rip and dip dude yeah he's doing like
a beautiful piece of artwork too right
like there's
you know it's art it's like he like he
literally read like i think like i don't
know how many bucks
i'm probably gonna overestimate a little
bit here but he's somewhere like 50
books
like in preparation for this one thing
he wrote a book to write the story
oh my god i'm like hype i'm like hyping
this guy up a little bit
but not that much the guy's amazing i'll
have him on the show eventually
but anyway go check it out what is
happiness will scooter uh scooter
get the mug man support this man yeah
good friend
he's doing god's work he's doing
incredible work man yeah it's so tight
well people are just like
when you watch the show you really like
like real you realize people don't
understand happiness
and it's like we live in one of the most
depressed lonely disconnected times ever
and it's never been more important to
understand your own personal happiness
and it's like people just don't want to
sit down for 46 minutes and understand
it now you have no excuse
now you have no excuse 46 minutes it'll
be entertaining and it's just
it's so important to be happy yeah man
okay cool but yeah man
uh good episode thank you guys for
watching as always thanks for coming to
our demonetized
uh podcast we appreciate you guys we
love you guys
as always write us at laughingbabbles
gmail.com
um we will get to more of the episodes
but uh i mean
blocked us out of the account so i know
i know and we'll we'll get more
we'll yeah we we have other people like
ananya thiagy
said she's sentencing bart hobank now
anyone asked us for advice
no they sent us like scams and [ __ ] i
need you guys to tell me that you're
like we need to hear about your problems
yeah we need to hear about that and like
look to be honest i think a lot of you
guys are
buying into some crypto king of course
king uh bitcoin king
because i am getting people being like
hey love the show you guys are great you
call it out
go to his instagram that's a crypto king
yeah we need we need we need to hear
from you guys now all the christians all
of them
yeah yeah all of them yeah yeah write us
in uh and
i guess that's it we'll see you guys
next time yeah we'll see you guys next
time thank you guys for listening peace
you can use your charms
but you got a tough cell
[Music]
i know
[Music]
but you won't ever get your papers on me
or you can train me to your family tree
but you won't ever get your papers on me